now let me ask you this okay when today
Jim Norton is in town I did his radio
show with Sam Roberts and kalila calls
me and goes is that Laurel
do you hear Laurel oh my gosh you did
the same thing a man right so then I and
then Jim looks at me go it's Laurel [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] Laurel right I hung up and
they did the test for me yeah we should
do it right now yeah everyone okay so
everyone you're listening on yeah what
was the thing on the internet with the
the dress everyone knows the blue gold
dress I saw both so you know I never I
only saw one in this case I really
wanted to hear both but I only heard a
man's voice saying Laurel yeah what what
is it what else is they hear from me
Jonnie Jonnie I heard that a variation
of that heard yeah me yeah which is with
Jessica heard she hears yeah me he does
yeah I hear ya me not yeah there's some
a small percentage of people that hear
yeah me instead of Yanni
but it's Laurel how the [ __ ] do they
listen to let the audience decide let's
hear it yeah put your comment after you
hear this
oh it's wait that's Laurel I heard
Laurel yeah it's Laurel Laurel out there
I heard yeah me Jules its what are you
here
Laurel Jana can you come in here real
quick and tell me okay hang on it sounds
different
it sounds Laurel with the headset for me
yeah I take it off it says yeah me yeah
what are you here yeah me you here yeah
me okay I'm gonna put my whole morale
now all I hear is Laurel do you really
here yeah me here oh my god she's one of
those get out of my house you're a witch
No you're so scared yeah eat something
god it's the Laura the law yeah I did
not get moral until it now all I hear is
Laurel okay well I wonder what that I
want that's crazy so we're now you're a
scientist tell me what it is so the
explanation is that it's more of a
mechanical thing of our ears being able
to pick up on different frequencies so
if that audio actually has both a
high-pitched Yanni or Yanni I think I
don't know I've never heard it and a low
male voicing Laurel yeah some people can
hear both frequencies of sound some
people can only hear like a lower
register some people can only hear a
certain one but it's the free so it goes
dude um people listen here Laurel then I
don't think I think like because they
use the first they were saying oh only
old people hear Laurel but it's like
there were young kids who heard Laurel
and older people who heard Yanni so yes
so I don't want to hear Yanni so bad I
mean her both notes so we're both but
what happened next I did for a second I
can only hear yeah me as soon as I put
this on I met Laurel I think that some
people can hear a different one if it's
further away from them so I don't I
don't know I I can't hear ya or there's
nobody I was with nobody I was with Jim
or Sam heard Yanni that's an interesting
thing yeah
[Music]